Danny you okay I don't think any of us
are okay I don't even know what I came
means anymore so we're gonna we're gonna
break this down real professionally like
game by game right but could we just
take like 20 seconds what the [ __ ] was
that again oh my god know what they're
doing they got earlier right yeah wait
in my palms no BS entirely acted Olin
trail off the trail a trip no there's no
like slowing down at all no they're like
yo new kijima game baby
norman reedus naked god of war live
demos yeah everything David cages game
looks alright even Peter was like I'd
buy that dude I'm into it new spider-man
game I mean we called so much of the
stuff Resident Evil can be like it start
to finish in virtual reality play it
tonight you can play the demo tonight
see you guys I'm out all right okay
let's shake off the cobwebs stop
thinking about Norman Reedus is naked
eyes and a c-section we'll get to that
in a second okay where to start you know
what actually does just start with that
death stranding that is the new game
from Hideo Kojima and Kojima Productions
Peter Brown a little bit of a sort of a
clue towards this we saw on Jeff
Keeley's YouTube live show earlier today
yeah Jeff Healey had kijima on YouTube
and he was like you know you're always
someone who likes to sort of play with
expectations and you know you drop
little hints when people least expect it
and could use it oh yeah yeah I don't
know for all we know maybe your shirt is
giving something away here's like oh
there's lairs des with some strands
hanging from it yeah so it was 100% of
hints and Wow yeah okay who wants to
tackle this one that's trying to figure
out what game this is here's Norman
Reedus with electronic handcuffs a baby
with a wire yep that's a baby it's a
little bit Wireless baby this happens
all over him
super happy that the baby is cutting to
me I missed the baby where the baby go
that's slightly healthier looking baby
than in PT yeah they show that the baby
disappears I don't know baby
the hideo kojima's making a new video
game Alexa yes he is it's called but
isn't it death stranding and Norman
Reedus is in it and that's all we know
ok the hands and say look I'm Prince
Mohan France we good well we're were
three for three are doing we're doing
we're doing hands out hands that yeah oh
I
all three okay looks good look at that
scar oh my god like it's oh my god there
is so much symbolism in this I don't
even know where to be getting like all
these random being six out dog tags
honor me hogging the dog tags I don't
know like it looks like like little like
yeah like few songs and then if you saw
in the sky they're like these weird
thing yeah like I've closed if I'd thing
men like icons of humans or something
Ken reminded me of a Evangelion like
what they had bits of the Angels that
were on the crosses right yeah okay yeah
there you go that's that's that's it
that's what he do kijima is up to now
nothing to do with that Luden's
Luden's I wouldn't be surprised if it
did right what's Newton's Luden's is the
character you know their mascot that
they showed that teaser image oh oh yes
I mean it said I'll keep coming that was
the title of the song that they were
using over the trailer yes so presumably
it's more than just a mascot at this
point all right let's can we stop let's
not stop looking at this because I feel
like my I'm already assure that I'm
going to have nightmares about this this
evening so if we can just like create a
little bit of a buffer
you